gangster squad looks completely badass  in a day and age where true stories are  shot to look as real as possible  gangster squad takes the brave choice of  going for a uniquely stylish awesome  visual experience extravaganza the  costumes set pieces locations the  production design just looks superb the  cinematography appears grand the acting  looks [ __ ] solid just the idea of  josh brolin and ryan gosling being in  the same movie together makes me wanna  come it's interesting because brolin  gets top billing but ryan gosling is  featured way more in the trailer oh my  ryan sean pan also looks like he really  delivers emma stone is [ __ ] sexy she  also makes me wanna come with all the  elements of cast and crew working  strongly together to bring a fun-filled  action-packed drama fun filled drama i  cannot wait to see gangster squad ryan  wright thinks gangster squad could get  it right